i just rewatched the first uh episode of
uh
[ __ ] snowfall as you see snowfall oh
yes you know like that first episode the
fbi agent
i think a [ __ ] blows cocaine up his ass
and he dies or it's the other way no no
he blows cocaine up her ass and she dies
and then he has to clean up the body
i set out to say have you ever snored
cocaine off of a woman's [ __ ] yes how
was that oh incredible
i think i did it to my wife to be honest
i mean my wife you know my wife's sober
now
when we first got together i was the
doctor
yeah shout out to my wife man she's
she is the sober one and but she was
like
a [ __ ]
mad woman
when i first got with her you know i
think the first five times i seen her i
just i just asked her for a bump in a
xanax bar
like in past and i was like you gotta
bump she's like yep and she'd feed me a
[ __ ] just big old [ __ ] hogger and
then i'd be like later that night i'd
bump into her again at some bar or
something cause so you know i'd be like
you got a xanax she's like yep she'd
like she was like a pest dispenser of
drugs that's [ __ ] great yeah
literally she was just like the [ __ ]
she was the mountain fairy in the
bathroom right she was back to you know
she was just running around just feeding
everything if you do too much cocaine
it's hard to [ __ ] on that right oh well
[ __ ] i mean we've already discussed my
struggles i knew i would need a blue two
times two and a miracle he'll say
[ __ ]
is it harder to [ __ ] when you're the
size you are
in terms of just like the geometry of
the situation like playing [ __ ] uh
twister
left foot on yellow right hand on red
move this here set this on your back
he'll say it turn this way i mean i feel
like you were you did have an error
though where you lost a lot of weight i
did yeah yeah yeah i did and believe it
or not let's be clear i'm i'm i'm down
like 25 30 pounds i joke right i'm
taking my health sears i go see my
cardiologist every three months but
you're trying to get yourself i'm losing
the weight at a good rate i don't want
to lose it too fast because of the heart
but people are going to want to see
nothing bad happen to you like look i
used to do cocaine and sip lean y'all
i'm gonna be okay you're gonna be fine
don't worry about me i'm
i'm all right i'm being facetious more
often than not but um
yeah it's like [ __ ] i lose the weight
again pandemic just [ __ ] did it to me
you know just [ __ ] me too i never had
to sit still i lost like 40 pounds oh
dude
yeah i gained 40 pounds you know what's
crazy you you were like me though i
never had to sit
yeah it was like the first time from
years of touring that god was just like
no you're gonna just sit here you guys
you had to cancel some shows too oh [ __ ]
a whole tech nine tour that's right 57
cities or something tour never happened
it's the best tour that never took off
wow i forgot that [ __ ] heartbreaking
now we have a goal record together that
we've never even performed creatures
gold gold yes sir me him and calico jeez